[Music]
the great critique of this place Davos
is that it's completely cut off from The
Real World down there people face a cost
of living crisis up here not so much
even so inflation and energy are still
at the top of the agenda ask the
presidents of Latvia and Lithuania where
they're battling 20 plus inflation the
inflation is one of the highest in
Europe in Latvia but is going down
already in the last months of 22 and
we're expecting that in 23 we will have
a much more lower inflation as 22. yes
of course inflation remains high and you
know that inflation is still above 20
but we see some signs of stabilization
and very likely that we will see the
reduction of inflation rate in the
second half of the year
and in a way that message that things
are slightly improving might just be the
main economic takeaway from Davos
surprising as it might sound the noises
coming out of the world economic Forum
are actually quite
quite Positive Growth a bit stronger
inflation a bit weaker than those
previous miserable forecasts but of
course that all depends on it not being
too cold in Europe this winter and
crucially on its supply of energy
and there's good news on that front too
the Ukrainian national gas company has
just sealed a deal here in Davos to
secure its energy supplies for the
winter
I'm of Ukrainian household will receive
natural gas this winter it is very
important to secure appropriate volumes
of gas and I'm happy to announce that we
have reached all appropriate agreements
with our partners and allies to secure
that volume for this winter even so for
Europe the continent most affected by
the price shock there is no time to
waste for a lot of time we haven't paid
enough attention to where we get our
critical raw material and commodities
from including energy and we had kovid
then we had the war and now we need to I
think this wake-up call has has worked
so there's huge diversification going on
in terms of countries and they're
supplying energy and in terms of what
type of energy One is using
the problem is that shifting these
things takes time and it can take even
longer for the benefits to trickle down
into our homes our pockets and our lives
at Conway Sky News and Davos